hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
I'm just checking in on use as you can
hear the chuckling in the background we
have a very special guest here very
special it's becoming I'm becoming more
social with my podcast and it's good I
should open up a little I know I usually
don't have guests too often what the
[ __ ] am I doing with this this is what
becomes the problem cuz I had my little
system how to do we have the wonderful
Tom papa Dan ten intent well it's easier
if people call you to do the podcast
rather than you having to chase them
like that's the worst part about writing
gay let's let's be smart here and
promote what we have to promote okay
let's all you're not here just because
you love me and you love hanging out and
here in my diarrhea the mouth has
nothing to do with nothing to do with it
has to do with the fact that you have a
new stand-up special streaming right
[ __ ] now Netflix called you're doing
great you're doing great on Netflix
what's your bitching you're doing great
always aren't that bad you gotta realize
that you I know you're filled with
anxiety I know you feel like you're fat
in your but that doesn't mean you're not
doing great
yeah I just think of the life you live
in that you could become fat yeah right
exactly yeah how about that how about
that what's the heaviest you'd go the
heaviest night you weren't this business
then he worked alone from home right no
one was gonna judge you
you know yeah but you're a lover of food
the heaviest I've ever been okay was 210
210 how tall you I'm 511 fire on the
5-11 here under 511 yeah 210 210 you
that was the fattest I've ever been that
was after that was after Italy pure
blubber you know everyone's always like
you go to Italy eat their bread and you
eat their gelato and it's not like in
America you don't get fat oh yeah that's
[ __ ] came back with very tight
fitting everything yeah well you don't
get as fat right you definitely get fat
I mean if you read up on that [ __ ] Dube
like we're trying to force countries to
take our food yeah and then
like we're not taking that [ __ ] so then
they created this Court this
International Supreme Court these
corporations did and that we've decided
you have to take our food now and then
they go alright well then we're gonna
say what's in it they're like no you're
not that's what we're eating
well yeah these [ __ ] people was
sitting there saying you Americans are a
bunch of fat [ __ ] it's like you come
over here yet you try and do it you
[ __ ] you chow down some [ __ ] GMOs
and some trans fats yeah you do we're
being poisoned yeah really being poison
that's why I always come back to the
bread you know I'm obsessed with me
baking bread but it's real bread it's
flour water salt and yeast and for all
these years like Trek like trying to get
healthy bread for my family
you can't do it I know it's very
difficult to get it without sugar and
without all these extra additives and
stuff I can't even pronounce
we were really being poisoned and it's
it's difficult even when you think
you're picking out stuff that's good for
you there's a good chance however you're
doing great everyone's doing great but
uses denial if this is just a way to
like try to like navigate whatever the
fun is that's that this impending thing
that we feel like is gonna be happening
you know you can wait your whole life
though for that to happen that's right
that's that's what I was starting to
feel when I was out on tour I'm like
talking to people and I'm realizing that
they're filled with anxiety and they're
watching news all the time in they're
getting obsessed with this kind of like
sense of panic or not even panic like
looking at other people on social media
and seeing other people's lives and
thinking that their life pales in
comparison and it's like no no this is
all an illusion you're the human being
that has to digest all this stuff no
other human brain has had to do that so
just tune that out and realize a simple
life is fine you're doing great than
what I did I took my daughter and wife
we went to my daughter's dance class
uh-huh and my wife's so cool she's like
oh you know there's a library on the way
here and we checked out some books I'm
like you nerd I go that's so cool and I
went in there and I was hanging out and
I saw up on the up there you know we
check out books they had a rumble
looked at it and the printing was big it
was 135 pages I'm like this is in my
wheelhouse yeah i sat down that thing
yesterday read the whole thing I mean we
have typing it's usually about 55 60
pages huh and absolutely loved it wasn't
on my phone felt chill afterwards I
wasn't scatterbrain I loved the ride
that the book took me on yeah and that's
a simple pleasure
well it really is the cell phone though
and I'm the biggest you know you're
guilty of this is like this morphine
drip of anxiety it's like this IV bag
that is just stuck into your [ __ ] arm
and I I get you know where I get all my
news yeah no I can't I click on the
magnifying glass on Twitter to see
what's trending oh god I know it's so
bad the worst it's just poison it's
literally poison well I was in a fox coz
that's gonna be totally biased
yeah that's poison too I know how bad is
the [ __ ] thing with did you see that
okay so stupid that his speech last
night you know what he's done yeah
[ __ ] that other idiot rips it up it's
like am i watching the Vince McMahon
right this okay watching like a
wrestling promo can you guys act like
[ __ ] adults and it's just like
anything that that her side of the table
was gonna get you they lost in that
moment to that stupid thirsty as the
kids say grandiose thing you wear a blue
[ __ ] bra we know you don't like what
red panties said they need to do that
and he comes and he doesn't shake your
hand in the beginning no it's ridicu
know like some little kid and the
problem is you can as you're paying
attention to all this stuff and you're
going through like even inane stuff like
on social media just looking at your
friends and family or celebrities that
you're following years are just peeling
by and this is it like right now like
this is prime time for us this is like
the good years
as a human being an adult you only get
like a certain chunk why would you spend
it polluting your mind and body with all
of this horrible no I go on Facebook I
get depressed I start looking up old
friends and classmates and a guy here
old I'm old I'm hoping things are
working out for ya and but it's just
something about there's just something
like I there's just something about I
don't know what it is but it's like I
had that thought the other thing after
right before I went to bed it was on
Facebook or something like that
and I woke up in the morning and my
first thought was the amount of decades
that I've been in all the 70s all the
age all the 90s all the mm all the teens
yeah [ __ ] I'm in my sixth Dec seventh
decade because I was born in 68 I'm just
like yeah what the [ __ ] yeah that's my
philosophy is don't don't do the math
but it's so hard not to no no you should
definitely that that whole [ __ ]
[ __ ] nobody lives in the moment yeah
nobody does like a dog does our brain
you can't do that this hope you know
take well all of these yoga classes and
[ __ ] you can't [ __ ] do it here's the
one thing I've kind of been thinking
about in regards to that lately is that
you can't do it you can't live
blissed-out and just la Tita this is
just the flowers are great and the Sun
is this is wonderful but you can take it
you can probably get three to five
minutes of that in your day you know
what I mean
I'm just being grateful like oh I shot a
special my podcast is going well I've
got a daughter who's just gonna dance
class this this is actually pretty good
three minutes five minutes and then get
back to work and get back to letting
your brain go and I think if you were
able to do that like three five minutes
a day that's a pretty big achievement
for a human brain well now it is yeah
I'm finding now that I like I try to
leave my cell phone in a different room
and it's it's yeah raizy he's a
difficult it is so hard I just had the
[ __ ] thing there yeah be my wife we
[ __ ] yeah let's watch this TV show right
which is stupid we've never used to have
a TV in the bedroom now we do and we'll
just be sitting there and then like just
in different times during the show
all of a sudden she's on her phone yeah
I'm on my phone something said and then
I look it up yeah and and I'm thinking
you know all the work somebody made the
14-hour days to create this [ __ ]
thing over how many months yeah and I'm
gonna spend half of it looking at my
phone checking you're like watching
Nancy Pelosi tear up the speech at Trump
after Trump didn't shake her hand yeah
and then read the comments of somebody
such a [ __ ] idiot that they're gonna
[ __ ] sit there and try to get people
going yeah and start a fight now oh
great we can all fight on this now look
at this guy's we can fight on they're
like dogs with like a bone yeah I almost
commented on something today because
there was something on the tight end for
the San Francisco 49ers there was a
video of him standing on the sidelines
when 49ers knew they were gonna lost
yeah lose he was just like this isn't
gonna define me I'm definitely gonna be
back I'm not going out like this and
blah blah blah blah and then all these
[ __ ] [ __ ] who didn't play in the
Super Bowls and yeah that's what
everybody says yeah yeah [ __ ] try me
you dig it [ __ ] you Dan Marino said that
you guys are mad that this guy is taking
a crushing defeat in a positive way
right like right yeah what's wrong
exactly yeah I don't know it's the noise
the noise and look I do it too I
participate in it I dive into it I get
all muddy with it but I really feel like
I just felt like in the act like wrote
itself from the reaction that the people
were having when I was doing it we were
coming up to me after the show and
saying like relieved like no like total
sincerity no cynicism thank you thank
you for saying we're doing great she was
you know I feels good raising my kids
and I think it's all going alright and
but then I feel like this I don't know
why it really started to feel so
positive yeah that I just kept drilling
into it and I'm I feel like for us the
cool thing is like you can go off and
work on your you need something to work
on we can go work on our act or you can
get like really into coffee or you get
really into scratch yeah or you know
what I mean or bread
seriously those things that there
there's much more important than we
think and definitely more important than
all this stuff that we have on our phone
yeah we have so I don't know the cigar
thing we were started talking oh we
start talking with that yeah yeah I had
to quit him quit
I ended quit well I mean it was up was
it like I have it like you getting itchy
if you didn't have one no it's just I
have that thing what I don't have like
it I don't get itchy I just think like I
want to do that and then I just do it
right so yeah it's the same reason why I
try not to have ice cream cookies and
candy around cuz I'll [ __ ] eat it
right so I can't have booze around cuz
I'll drink it if I got cigars around I'm
gonna smoke them but yeah but if you
take them away yeah I'm not like clawing
at the [ __ ] walls and running out to
buy more Sh I just go we're all gone oh
yeah well now what now what can I obsess
about I'm gonna learn the top three
[ __ ] lines of every team in the NHL
I'll go do that instead of eat candy I
have the weirdest [ __ ] brain so I
have to I've finally learned after half
a goddamn century yeah that I really
have to pay attention to what it is
right I'm getting into that's smart
that's really smart
that's a very self-aware thing to you
well I mean I had fifty years to [ __ ]
figure it out that 51st year
I'll [ __ ] figure it out so yeah I
haven't boozed to them you know like
quit I am
no booze either I haven't quit I quit at
the end of 2018 November 2018 you
haven't had a drink since then no not
one drink no wow yeah Wow sucks do you
consider yourself like sober like like
Norton sober no I wouldn't say that
because occasionally I'll take an edible
I don't like smoking weed I don't like
putting smoke in my lungs yeah funny
I'll [ __ ] have a marinating in my
mouth yeah another thing I was just like
oh so I'll just get jaw cancer this is
stupid
so in all cigar smokers
guys I'm sitting there in a cigar bar
breathing in all of our [ __ ]
secondhand smoke stupid yeah having said
that you know once a year during the
Rose Bowl sitting on the golf course
right [ __ ] Joe bartnik and yeah all
the guys I love just [ __ ] that that's
when you have actual occasion stuff yeah
I feel so I think I'm gonna dry out for
like three months and then I'm gonna you
know great one well you know what
happens is once you start smoking cigars
then you meet all these people that
smoke cigars
yeah and it's a very social thing and
they want to do it with you that's right
because it's such a gross thing to
everybody else that if you fight in
another animal it does it I think you
like latch onto them because everyone
else is like oh like even even like my
wife forget it and then my friends and
then you find Robert Kelley he's like
dude let's go let's go oh yeah I mean it
was just like like there wasn't enough
reasons to love Bobby Kelly now he will
smoke a cigar anytime anywhere anywhere
and anything you're doing like this guy
do my taxes why don't you come by we'll
smoke a couple of bats a couple of
chairs right in front of his office and
he just like that's awesome let's do
that I know it's such a great thing
because there are like there is this
thing I don't know what it is it's
because that is its relaxing and there's
no phone in all of that so you kind of
put all that stuff away you put all that
stuff down and what I love about when I
go into cigar bars is you know if I've
gone into those things by myself and the
next thing you know I'm [ __ ] talking
to somebody yeah and it's a very like
hey what are you smoking Baba a lot of
guys their their sports fans a lot of
guys that run their own businesses as
it's sort of a I've never met like a
douche
yeah really that is I'm sure there are a
few but you're generally speaking like
cigar smokers are cool mm-hmm just
really because they're out there killing
it doing something and then that was
just like you're catching them in this
relaxing yeah philosophy how they smoke
where it's just like you know I do it I
do it every Sunday
I have this I you know I built this
little thing my wife is fine with it
they had the whole whole little thing
that they do you I got out of control
with them I just dialed it back you know
my kids give me a rough time we all have
the same [ __ ] every was the same stir
everything you just said is my prop like
I used to I was starting to do more
often but now I've got teenage daughters
uh-huh and they're just like slamming
doors shut and like coming out oh I was
gonna sit out here I guess I'm not and
then looking back inside and you're like
there's there's one of the precious
moments that I'll have with my kid
totally and and even up to the point
where I didn't want to like stink like
it
like I'd do it before they come home
from school but now look dad you smell
so all right so now I've blown that our
two I can't hang out with them now so it
just became this thing where everything
in my life was up against me how old is
he he's 74 I love it yeah he just shrunk
the size of them he drinks that he
smokes those like nubs like they loved
those things daddy a Christmas party
about that yeah yeah nubs I love the
nuts yeah he really like that you did
shorter he gets his fix but he does it
every single well I bought him doubt I
do that podcast you know once a month
with Bert Kreischer the bill birth
podcast and so we were to smoke cigars
which you know was gonna look obnoxious
so we just decided to smoke these really
big stupid ones no cigars still like a
90 gauge it looks like a [ __ ] Delhi
pickle yeah
so we smoked one of those [ __ ] things
it's like Cape Fear right do it it was
just like yeah you like a [ __ ]
blow-up doll mouth trying to [ __ ]
suck on those things and something
happened that day know where I was
walking out to my car and I was I wasn't
limping but I wasn't walking straight
people were going like hey bill what do
you think yeah okay yeah what I just
added it
turns out you alright yeah yeah I'm fine
in the car yeah it was like three months
with the nicotine yeah that's bad that
happened oh you leavin here one time or
your old place oh there was we had a
pretty big one yeah and like I just had
one scotch one it wasn't it wasn't much
but I got into the car like I don't know
if I'm gonna throw up or just be dizzy
the rest of my life like you have to
like yes or nothing I I had a I have
Kevin Shea came over one time and he
smoked a cigar and he puked via Bartnik
were there we see started to call you
know Reggie Jackson was mr. October we
started calling him mr. May already been
smoked and he came over after us and he
wasn't a big cigars I felt bad because
he I think he liked cigarette smokers
when they don't man a cigar their their
tendency is to inhale yeah I think
that's what he did he had a couple of
drinks but he's such a ride he was
laughing his ass off about it so awful
but what was good was it probably cured
him of of that habit but I love I love
them yeah I went to a Super Bowl party
and this guy had this amazing selection
of him and I walked up like six times
during the game and I never smoked when
I just sort of write like smelled them
like ah yeah I know it is a nice thing
but you know the specials out I feel
like a you know a milestone you always
have those little milestones in your
head and it's like I thought well when I
shoot it I'll have one and I didn't and
then I know it comes out I figure I'll
do it but my family's all around and I'm
still be all those times that I'm not
doing it this is where you know it's
kind of addicting yeah you I think about
it every day there isn't a day that goes
by where I don't think about well maybe
today maybe I can work it in today yeah
you know the same thing would happen to
me with weed I was like stopped weed I
wasn't funny anymore on it it was
uncomfortable I just cut it out of my
life every day since then I think it's
what smoke weed or anything like that no
that's good no that's a good thing I
like drinking but even that's kind of
like weaning a little bit because
just you know I'm getting up early and
it's just you know drink we used up all
your fun days true I was talking about
that on my podcast where if I could give
you any advice uh-huh
first of all don't buy anything yeah
don't great advice [ __ ] buy anything
you don't need it and it's just gonna be
[ __ ] you're gonna have to look look at
all the [ __ ] knickknacks I got in
this goddamn things just [ __ ] people
gave me yeah this is I was here when
this room was pretty empty yeah
so yes a lot it's just a bunch of [ __ ]
and then and then you just have all of
this [ __ ] and then you die and then
people have to come in and figure out
what to keep and what to throw out you
give him a job
so I was telling him that and then I was
telling him on the party and stuff is go
easy yeah pace yourself yeah I'm not
gonna say the name but this was one of
the coolest stories ever all right I'm
not gonna say who was this a person I
know do I know them yes bought a house
typical time I'm gonna break this down
and figure out who this do I know them
are they older or younger than us male
or female male and that's all you get
all right so this dude bought this
[ __ ] house on this quiet street right
and he was like everybody on this street
is [ __ ] cool except this one old lady
down the street and she's in her 90s and
she has people over like almost every
night and they [ __ ] drink and play
music and have a good time and I'm like
she either has like ridiculous it's
probably both yeah genetics or she
always just you know I bet there's food
involved there's a whole he has the
people she has the people over she's the
one that has cars on the street 92
I think 95 oh my god
yeah like way the [ __ ] up there yeah she
has all these friends and they come over
and they play cards and they eat and
they drink and they cackled that's an
amazing [ __ ] great time and and if
there's ever a time to do that almost
every night it's when you're in your 90s
Oh 100% no one can say hey watch you
drink and you could be dude I could be
dead tomorrow
give me a [ __ ] martini thank you stat
yes yeah my last night of martinis ever
that's right this could be my final mark
martini so and I would like to enjoy it
without your [ __ ] life advice if you
don't mind I think it's guy though I
just thought it was the but alright that
I totally agree but shouldn't we be
living that way also cuz newsflash you
could be dead tomorrow
yes you know what I mean yeah if
anything from that Kobe [ __ ] that was
just like yeah how could not everybody
got that I could not shake and it is
everybody's talk about the daughter I
just could not [ __ ] like yeah like
that was that I'm telling you I'm sure
that was but I was joking with everybody
for sports fans yeah that was our lady
died uh a lady died like the whole world
was like oh my god she was in the primer
life of blah blah blah and like as much
as I was like this is terrible is just
tragic and I felt real bad for the two
boys I wasn't in that world so I didn't
feel like that taken thing I mean like
with with the Kobe thing it was just in
his daughter and then also like I also
like I didn't I didn't know anything
about you know his daughter or anything
like that I learned all of that stuff
after he died but I saw these pictures
of his daughter and the way she smiled
when she was with him be exact it's like
anybody can get that smile when your
daughter's three yeah to get that one
you're 13 you're a great [ __ ] dead
that's what I was looking at that going
like I want to have my kids smiling at
me like that at 13 that's [ __ ]
incredible and then just the way that
that was like taken away but yeah the
life is short part of it the life is
short part of it definitely but like I
don't want be life is short because I'm
posing and drinking but if I get hit by
a [ __ ] bus that's one thing but like
that you can also like this you don't a
self-inflict
the end I don't know how to do what my
mother has always said any time we have
discussions like this it's always a
whole group of my family we're all
together you should do this and more
vegetables and blah blah blah we have
all these new AG things and then she
just yell
from the other room because we all know
she's right she is right she's
absolutely right I should be able to
once a week sit down and have a nice
martini and [ __ ] once a month smoke a
delicious [ __ ] cigar yes yes what Tom
I don't know how to [ __ ] do that that
I do not have those life skills yeah
yeah I always I always think I this is
what a gentleman would do he would have
one martini and what's wrong with this
and halfway through that first martini
I'm like I gotta get to the next one's
gonna be and then it's like thinner than
three in and I'm and it's just asleep
yeah oh this is the level of buzz I need
I do miss some yeah when I came to my
house for a martini that would be a good
plan like you just come I can keep the
booze because I don't scarf it down if
it's in the house and you stop at my
place once a month one cigar one martini
that's a nice way to live this feels
like a Netflix series well shoot one a
month the sort of sober guys yeah the
thing about it is I just don't have the
confidence listen if I didn't have a kid
right now I would take that I would make
that bet she's changed everything
yes yep so my [ __ ] was this was my [ __ ]
yeah my [ __ ] was everybody's in bed
uh-huh I have an ice bottle of bourbon
yeah and I put on me-tv and I would
watch 77 Sunset Strip or Peter Gunn and
I'd have like five of them and I would
just sit up and just get absolutely
[ __ ] hammer in my own house it was
awesome it sounds it was [ __ ] awesome
man
in 77 Sunset Strip oh yeah I I I love
the cars and everybody on it was smoking
it drink it was the guy one of the guys
on 77 Sunset Strip II he's always Benton
the horses he was a degenerate gambler
they're all smoking
they're all [ __ ] banging broads the
[ __ ] guy Efrem Zimbalist jr. had a
new Thunderbird every season every
season he had the new Thunderbird and
then they've just [ __ ] sucking down
booze and I was just like this I missed
this is the time that sounds great
walked around you had a suit on for no
[ __ ] reason all day long Jason
[ __ ] perps through bushes in Anderson
little suit yeah you know and then he's
no great that is so perfect that line he
said hey you got a pretty active elbow
for lunchtime or something like that
talking about this guy up he said this
[ __ ] I forget how he's active he's
drinking yeah cuz he was on like his
start you know he's playing the role
though the booze out it was a guy into
playing the professor on Gilligan's
Island that's another thing I'd love to
do it where I would look up who's this
actor who's this guy like I found like
one of those episodes I watched some
Peter Gunn I found like the first
african-american guy to get his sag card
wow that guy's really good who is that
guy he was like really old right a
[ __ ] crush the part I saw a young
Gavin MacLeod playing a gangster it's a
no bald
amazing in like 1950 he was riding I
they killed this guy in the back of a 55
Chrysler New Yorker or the Chrysler
Imperial I always get those two cars
confused it was a 1955 stretch yeah
stretch limo foot back then which men it
was about three feet longer with a
little bar in there they whack this guy
in the beginning then there was this
dude playing racquetball he was this
sinister [ __ ] guy go to who the [ __ ]
is this guy like and I looked it up oh
my god
nobody called a man hey yeah he was
great on Mary Tyler Moore yeah oh my god
he was so great how many days a week
would you do this
oh like six Wow like I just it just
became this thing that I would I would
do yeah it was every other night that it
just became every night and then my my
growing up playing sports
would be how I would look at the bottles
I can defeat that thing in three nights
a third a third and third right that was
just it just didn't make any sense and
then I got into like the ice cubes yeah
and there was a guy down in El Segundo
who made these [ __ ] glasses I still
have them they're great where there's a
giant what looks like a giant ice cube
in it but it's also made out of glass
it's super heavy so then you put it in
the the refrigerant class ice cube is
actually mad at a glass so you don't
have any liquid so it's a perfect thing
if you had it whip wiggle or something
yeah rare cast by McCallum yeah you put
it in there and it would chill it 360
right right but not on the bottom not on
the top and then you just [ __ ] the
only thing was it was heavy as [ __ ]
oh really heavy glasses but they were
like you know homemade or whatever and I
ordered those I gave them to a couple of
my friends who drank and they all loved
him right and so I had that going on so
is this whole little your heads too busy
your head is too it's the ritual like I
love the ritual I love the whole [ __ ]
ritual of smoking a single oh I know I
think about you every time I smoke a
cigar
yeah because you got so into just the
match and how to light it and then and
then the reverse puffs at the end when
you get down to the last pony beans show
me that was the woody called gas you got
a gas to cigar first art station funny
in the middle of it or whatever he would
do this thing where he would light a
match and rather than draw in he blows
out yeah and then he takes in the end of
the cigars like lit like almost like
you're trying to light it then he pulls
it away and as he's blowing out that's
the oxygen that keeps the flame going it
looks like the back of the Batmobile
yeah degassing it you got a big ass it
and then you taste it and then your next
inhale you're the next draw it's it's
like clean yes I'm so dirty
yeah oh there's not the ash everywhere
yeah it's incredible I know no I think
about it all the time but you are very
much into just even the way he described
the car or you like every you you don't
go lightly you don't think about these
things lately they become an obsession I
do I got into Humphrey Bogart I started
watching all of his
[ __ ] films I did with Hargett Keitel
I did it with all of them yeah all the
[ __ ] great leading then Lee Marvin
all of them I just sat down and start
watching so I was watching I got to show
you the secret burger I do amazing but
what's-his-face newsflash I was watching
yeah Frank Sinatra stole so much of his
viber was inspired this right here I own
this thing here I'm a matchstick lighter
which doesn't work again this is from I
saw this in The Maltese Falcon
so that ma'am yeah so this was like I
saw him take this thing like this and he
just see that yeah yeah like it lights
and then this thing catches a little bit
of Flint here on the end of this I was
lit on fire and he litter cigarette and
so this this citizen in like lighter
fluid right look at the whole Art Deco
style of it and I literally looked up
I'm like what in the [ __ ] is that and
then I bought one and then I found this
[ __ ] guy in the middle of Michigan
who rebuilds them and I called him up
and he was like just that kind of guy is
just like what is it he knew what year
it was absolutely then I was telling him
like the whole thing he built that he
rebuilt he rebuilt the inside of it cuz
it didn't work so no so that was an
original from the era
oh yeah no this is this you command you
can buy these online filling heavy that
[ __ ] thing is that's beautiful
so I think I just need more lighter
fluid possibly in there yeah it looks
like at the bottoms a little yeah little
wonky yeah so and then I totally got
into that then I totally got into art
deco and the next thing you know I was
going online and I was looking at art
deco bars and I was gonna and I found
this amazing one that was I can check
lavake and I'm like you know it costs 4
grand and 80 grand is ship it over here
like okay I can't do that one there's
got to be somebody out there and I just
I just so I do that with with bows and
cigars and [ __ ] so I have to like really
ya know you mention I check I can't what
I learned is you can't bring the devil
into the house right you got to go out
to meet the devil you have the devil in
the house you guys gonna be hanging out
every [ __ ] night I had my I guess he
was my great uncle he's my mother's
uncle
and he would have him and his wife would
get dressed and they would have cocktail
hour every night and they would have he
had he was I think she would have a
martini and she would have a Manhattan I
think and they would both have their one
cocktail sometimes it went further but
the two of them just was this five
o'clock and they get dressed up and sit
with each other and have a little time
and if someone was visiting they would
be brought into the fold who did this is
that's amazing amazing amazing and he
lived a long life and similar to you he
got into flying and he had that same
obsessive kind of brain that he built
his own airplane
yep his own airplane that he was a Jeff
Dunham does that he just works with Rob
forever forever Jeff Dunham builds his
own helicopters Jeff Dunham is a [ __ ]
genius really nobody I saw this thing on
him one time I've said this I'm on a
bunch of podcast guy he's a [ __ ]
genius he first of all like having a
dummy in your act I didn't know this
[ __ ] uh-huh if you buy a dummy at a
store and then you make it you know you
start selling out clubs or arenas like
him yeah the maker of the dummy is gonna
be like well you owe us money because
that you're using our thing the branch
makes no sense because if I you wear
those shoes or whatever and they're not
gonna care but the dummy because it's
part of the Act
uh-huh they can come at you and it
becomes a big [ __ ] nightmare so he
goes alright I'll build my own dummies
right so the guy can draw amazingly and
he [ __ ] like designs these things
yeah and then he has like a 3d printer
that makes this thing and then he has
what it looks like I like a kitchen safe
like a little kitchen TV the big square
thing He pours the mold into it it cooks
it and then he paints the Hult that
alone yeah this way he's put more work
into his [ __ ] act and I have in my
entire career right it's really true
then they go oh yeah he's also one to
fly and he flies he'll look at this
before I think I was flying helicopters
whenever I didn't know that and he
builds his own like every year like it's
like experimental aircraft yeah that's a
homemade one right so the FAA hasn't
[ __ ] experimental means like people
think doesn't mean well well this
[ __ ] thanks fly
be kind of it is yeah a little pending
on sometimes we see the people that
they're basically sitting outside with
the put the [ __ ] the main rotor above
them you know and it looks like a little
go-kart like that but he has like legit
yeah
like helicopters in like he can fly the
[ __ ] out of him like yeah he is a he's
like one of those guys well you could
bring up like 20 different topics yeah
and he I was roundup he knows it I was
just gonna say what's crazy as I
interviewed him for I think an hour for
my radio show and then he'll never came
like he must he does so much that even
that never came up if I built my own
helicopter in Florida I would never shut
up about it yeah I would never shut up
about it this is my mother's uncle Uncle
Bob Bob Ulrich was his name and he was
just a classy dude and Anita was his
wife and they just were this great
couple and you know from the 40s on up
you know like that that generation and
cocktail hours and then he during the
day he'd go off to the hangar and he'd
work on that plane and build and work
out and took my father up in the plane
and fluid around dude that guy is like
he's amazing metal in the world
I know I know and that's why every day
he'd have one cocktail one cocktail yeah
that's the way we should do it I know
you I'm trying to put your obsession
towards that goal because I do think
that it is to be enjoyed you know and
what did he ever used to get [ __ ] up
yes he did because I always think once
you open that door know that you when
you start back up the first two three
times you're okay and then you just you
start sprinting no he and this is a kind
of fuzzy family folklore but I believe
that when they were younger they did it
you know whatever like and then it got
to be a bit of a problem and then was
petered off and then but his later years
again was down to just doing it as a
control thing and you know five o'clock
early so you know hammered all night and
you wake up fresh so yeah you know
like we all like kind of like let it get
a little out of out of our reach for a
little bit you know different things but
then there's doesn't mean you you know
if it didn't burn the house down right
you probably have it in you to be in
somewhat control of it and enjoy your
life just an idea yeah I don't maybe not
right away but maybe it's coming maybe
like in the in your next decade yeah I
think maybe when my daughter turns 21
all right a little bit of advertising
here oh but do me on DS be on DS no more
Billy drinks to do do do me on DS be on
DS he sober and he listens to pink oh
you know what that means love is in the
air some wouldn't grab the Lysol just
kidding even though this is made up a
made-up holiday that was their joke by
the way it's still really cute it's also
the perfect time to show I love that
everybody's onto the fact that this
really isn't a holiday now so now in
advertising they have to admit to it you
really know if they buy [ __ ] but it'd be
great if you did it's also the perfect
time to show that special someone how
much you care and say those three words
everyone wants to hear I only got you
underwear sorry match my undies the
undies has the most adorable Valentine's
Day prints to get all lovey-dovey this
year this is perfect cuz they're cute
women will love them they're not
expensive you get her in her pajamas you
know she's thinking of the bedroom and
you know maybe something happens don't
worry if you don't have a boo me undies
also make buddy bands so you can match
with your pet which is honestly more
important than people well that was kind
of a weird left turn to go there talking
about love with your pet we're in the
same pajamas this sounds like something
that happens in a rural area roses are
red violets are blue your butt is cute
rhyming is dumb Valentine's Day everyone
to show much they love you me undies has
not one but three new Valentine's Day
prints this year this is the perfect
opportunity to show that special someone
you're ready to take take it to the next
level with matching pairs now this is
come
match me so I know it's real is the
motto this year if you're matching your
BFF or even your dog it still counts
different prints colors and styles also
I swear to god they wrote that someone
told us that me undies has new
loungewear room it has it that it's
loungewear you can wear out and about
keep your eyes peeled for some cozy new
additions me undies has a great offer
for my listeners for any first-time
purchasers you get 15% off and free
shipping this is a no-brainer especially
because we have 100% satisfaction
guarantee to get your 15% off your first
pair free shipping and a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee go to the undies
comm slash burn that's me undies Emme
UND i es comm slash ber all right read
number two oh it's from honey
you know what you know that honey is
free online shopping tool that
automatically finds the best promo codes
and applies them to your cart and you
know how great it feels to save but how
does it feel to save with honey saving
with honey feels like sliding into a
seat on the train just before the doors
closed there's a whole bunch of examples
here hitting every green light on your
commute finishing up your podcast
episode right as you walk into work
feel free to insert your own endorsement
here squeezing out toothpaste and one
last time and there's enough for you to
brush your teeth efficiently sorry I'm
sober now I don't have any cool things
to say getting your pajamas out of the
dryer and they're still warm before you
go to bed after you have a cookie your
big cheat for the day all right
please interject a personal experience
of how honey has saved you money if you
recently saved on a gift for someone
mention that for instance what did you
buy Jesus Christ where's this person see
advertising honey is found it's over 18
million members over two billion dollars
in savings
did you know honey supports over 30,000
stores online including Macy's Target
Sephora Best Buy and more and they're
adding more every day use
love honey that's why it has over
100,000 five-star reviews on the google
chrome store using honey feels pretty
great think of it as a little daily
victory plus it's free to use and
installs in just a few seconds get honey
for free at join honey calm / / that's
join honey calm / / alright lastly but
not leastly simply safe everybody you
know every night local police
departments across America receive
hundreds of calls from burglar alarms
the vast majority of the time they have
no idea whether the alarm is real or
somebody's parakeet just died and hit a
[ __ ] window that opened who knows is
that really a crime going on or not
we got doughnuts day all the alarm
company you know they're eatin power
bars now come on you know cops are in
shape now all the alarm company can tell
them is the motion sensor went off
simply safe home security is different
if there's a break-in simply safe uses
real video evidence to give police an
eyewitness account of the crime that
means police dispatches up to three
hundred and fifty percent faster than
for a normal burglar alarm you get
comprehensive protection for your entire
home outdoor cameras and doorbells are
alert you to anyone approaching your
home entry motion and glass break sensor
guard inside Oh guard inside sorry Plus
simply say protects your home from fires
water damage and carbon monoxide
poisoning is 24/7 monitoring by live
security professionals you can set up
your system yourself no tools needed or
simply safe can do it for you and it's
only fifty cents a day with no contracts
visit simply safecom / / you'll get free
shipping and a 60 day risk-free trial
you got nothing to lose you go now and
be so go now and be sure to go to simply
safe calm / burst so they know our show
sent you
that's simply safe dot-com / bar did you
get freaked out by the helicopter thing
that it was a helicopter I mean I I knew
ya know and there was a really high hour
here like eight thousand eighty eight
hundred hours you know he was
instrument-rated
yeah and he had all and he was
incredible like you know I don't get too
much in detail buddy I'm in that world
so I know people that know people
whatever and like that guy was like you
know a great [ __ ] pilot yeah and the
fact that something like that could
happen yeah yeah that was definitely
ridiculously sobering well that's just
like you know I don't fly on days like
this
well those those conditions work yeah
any time I've been as a as a guest in an
helicopter if there was any kind of fog
or low visibility they just didn't go
yeah well yeah it's called the whole
thing off yeah - no go yeah well you're
yeah that's it's but people sit there
you know they they make too much about
like you know flying IFR and [ __ ] which
became like a mainstream little thing
there for a second yeah you just want to
tell people's like every time you fly
commercial for the most part unless you
get on some little puddle jumper yeah
you're always flying that right the
second you go above 18,000 feet
everybody
you know sets their altimeter 29.92 and
then you're all flying instrument right
rules right there so it's it's not like
this big mysterious thing yeah it's what
it's like it's just I don't know I I'm
gonna get into it because I'm not gonna
sit here and [ __ ] I'll be like those
[ __ ] who watch like the Superbowl
right and seconds late and blah blah
it's like I have 230 hours what the [ __ ]
do I know all I know is that the fact
that that could happen to somebody with
that much experience was devastating oh
my god it was devastating right a lot of
my buddies that have way more hours made
them not want to do it and just but it
was also everybody was caught up in the
emotion of it you got to kind of step
back after a couple weeks and let the
people who investigate do you think find
out what happened and then you kind of
make what you you know you live whatever
the [ __ ] you're gonna live with now it's
like you know I didn't I never flew but
I rode a motorcycle for a long time and
you know anything any weird story or
something it it shakes you in but you'd
also come back to well this isn't
anything new we knew this going in the
first day I put on a helmet I knew this
was a risk right so you it's not like if
it when they got me is I had a guy come
onto my show when I was down and still
one of the improv sand this guy came a
really nice guy
and he said you know is listen to your
podcast you know it really got me
through some stuff thank you I said what
happened cuz I got a motorcycle accident
mm-hmm and he wasn't doing anything
wrong he went through a green light this
old older couple just went through a red
light yeah weren't paying attention
crushed his leg and he had he lost his
leg and it was just like yeah yeah and I
was just like [ __ ] ouch walk you like so
let me ask you this so here's my big
question
mm-hmm I love big questions alright well
here's one foot
why is everything that's [ __ ] fun bad
for you yeah why can it all kill you why
why does fun always kill you because
motorcycles aviation drinking smoking
yeah with rich foods yeah right why is
everything that's not exciting make you
live forever
Brussels sprouts book smoothies yeah why
what is that [ __ ] it's like a big
[ __ ] joke because it's made this
[ __ ] thing you just Archie just
flipped that thing uh-huh right
I'll tell you what it is looking fun
that we would be having right now but
imagine yeah I mean it's an old hacky
bit but risky smoking cigars and boozing
yeah eating [ __ ] burgers and fries
gave you a six-pack we'd all look great
we don't look [ __ ] great we don't want
to bang each other which would keep the
[ __ ] human race going right we'd all
be happy I know the thing is things that
we do that take us to the edge make you
feel more alive they they make you feel
more present your feel more alive yeah
it makes you feel when you go up in a
helicopter or if I take off a hundred
miles an hour on a motorcycle
that's living and I gotta yeah you know
if you're not thinking about uh anything
else no everything is dialed in
everything is focused and then to a
lesser degree the drinking and smoking
you still are coming out of yourself
you're still going to an edge and those
things make you feel a lot very alive
and very present but you they're also
dangerous and you can't do them all the
time like you it's just the there's
there's a price to be paid for going all
the way there you know so it's tempting
because it does make you feel alive and
give you some sense of meaning but you
can't live there that's the problem
that's why I'm saying like the mundane
things that that give you meaning are
super important because they're it's not
the rush of going on your miles an hour
on a motorcycle and it's not you know
the crazy night of getting drunk and
doing your thing but it's just sitting
in the room while your daughter is
playing yeah that's so amazing
that's me the other night it's a small
mundane not dangerous not edgy thing but
you go to sleep at night I really
believe this you go to sleep at night
content because there's it's meaningful
all those other things are chasing what
real meaning is right it's a simulation
of what real mean yeah you know what
that might be something to that I tell
you I came off you know what the hell
was I I don't know I wouldn't I did the
Patrice benefit right yeah and we came
back and I literally I took like the
latest light I could take ya the first
flight it could take to get back you
know the deal right yeah I'm dad right
so I do it all the time
the dad the dad flights yep he see us
all getting on with their bad [ __ ]
genes
eight life getting back to the kid yep
so I got back in I got back you know all
the traffic and should I got back here
at time yeah for lunch
my daughter was was eating lunch and I
sat down next to her she was all excited
that I was there and she was sitting
there and she was you know drinking from
her little sippy cup and as she was
drinking
she just reached over and put her hand
on my forearm and I looked down like oh
my god and then she just smiled as she
was drinking and like not knowing what
she was doing right right and like on so
many levels
yeah I was just like oh my god this is
the greatest I love my daughter so much
she loves me and also she's open
emotionally she's touchy-feely all this
Shae I'm fixing all of this yeah it was
like on and I've thought about that like
[ __ ] and I mean it happened like a
couple Monday this week I've probably
thought about that at least 40 to 50
times yeah over the last few days where
I was kind of like yeah you know and as
they get older like they have more like
cognitive development you can really
like connect with them you know I was
giving her bath and she was just really
looking at me talking to me and I got
outside the conversation of just like
yeah I'm like having a conversation my
daughter this is unbelievable yeah yeah
so I think that that lasts longer than
they would a wheelie down a [ __ ] yeah
but the unfortunate part is you know
your brain
everyone's brain and your brain in
particular are very busy so even those
moments when you're sick really
important and you definitely get value
out of it still a lot of time in the day
still a lot of time your brains up and
away and it wants to go do something
else it wants to go to the edge of
something else and it's that's it's kind
of tricky okay you brain the right stuff
I'm a lunatic I am like I have to like
yeah I gotta like really pay attention
yeah to what it is I'm doing and try to
get outside of myself and look and be
like what the [ __ ] am i doing because if
I don't yeah
I will go down these these roads I will
get people in my life that I don't want
in my life
uh-huh or people that should be in my
life I miss him
yeah cuz I'm between my ears as they go
by right so I don't know well that's
amazing so you you were able to turn all
of this deep [ __ ] into [ __ ] comedy
yeah that's awesome well now I try this
it's gonna be another effortless [ __ ]
right 46 minutes just like that blowing
blowing through yeah all right so you
got your special it's it's called you do
great you're doing great on Netflix
right now and it's actually a stand-up
special that you can watch and feel good
about yourself you're not punching down
no you're not punching up no reaching
out saying you're doing great that's
pretty much that's a good subscribing
yeah I love it I'm gonna watch it when I
watch it tonight and yeah and also your
radio show my radio shows still going
with a fortune on Sirius XM fortune
females banging out the special system
oh yeah and her specials great - really
funny no [ __ ] she's so funny just
naturally she's been one of my favorites
yeah first time I saw her like I just
need to I just wish I could see or do
stand-up more I know every time I see
her she's working on it she like I
follow her on Twitter she's working on
some movie I know I'm happy for her but
as a fan to stand up I'm like [ __ ] I
know but her special is she nailed it
it's you know it's I was so proud of her
like I you know I've only been really
close with her for a short while but I
was really proud because it's not just
like a good special it's packed with
jokes like it's she's just bam bam bam
and it's meaningful it's got you know
her life story and it's really good and
so but we're doing that still four days
a week I'm serious yeah I remember way
back and I'm super early she was working
on Chelsea's show yeah and I remember I
used to say it all the time I mean it's
great you're on that show but I'm
telling you yeah you you are a star you
get you can go out yeah they make a
fortune on the [ __ ] road get back in
the clubs yeah I know she's like oh he's
so nice well she comes from she comes
from an improv background you know like
oh really yeah like The Groundlings
Duffy good lord she can do that too
yeah yeah I know she's well that's why I
hell's Lorne Michaels on this one yeah
Lord
get her in there right good point really
good point yeah that was she can do all
of that good ya know whatever everybody
gets what they're supposed to give she's
on a good path but I reckon you should
watch her special too
it's definitely good alright and yeah
everything's good man everything's great
everything's great but on brand yeah
and he makes bread and the and once
again I think that I always go over to
your house for Christmas Eve and yeah
this was your best meal I eat like a
[ __ ] pig at that that was good the
food was on point this year the sauces
yeah it was that one that wasn't the
meat sauce the other one the marinara
yeah oh my god it was on point yeah I
know that I was putting that on stuff
that already had it you seemed a little
frazzled this Christmas you seemed like
you were a little oh I'll tell you well
anxious cuz I double booked myself at
Christmas parties uh so Mike Price the
great Mike price from The Simpsons he's
the reason why f is for family is
chugging along the way it is uh-huh he
also had a [ __ ] Christmas party and
and then I you forgot and I told my
mother-in-law was going to Christmas Eve
Mass so I had to go Christmas Eve Matt
and I was fighting off a cold yeah you
were sick right so then I had to drop
everybody go to that the Christmas Eve
Mass Rach I loved doing and then yeah
it's fun dropped everybody off of your
house right drove over to Mike's made my
appearance there right sucking down
emergency and then I came all the way
back and I was thinking I my whole thing
was like Tom's gonna be smoking a cigar
I'm gonna miss it
so I came in and I was a little yeah I
was I was a little frazzled and then
also I was spent because a few days
before that I took my test for my
instrument writing the written test and
I've been studying for three four months
on that [ __ ] yeah yeah which was like
filling up all my free time and I just
passed that so I was kind of like I was
coming out of a lot of [ __ ] yeah that's
a good that's a good dad on Christmas
Eve I but I like that it's like in this
suit yeah just dealing with life dealing
with stuff and I gotta go home put the
presents together oh it was something
yeah I have all been wrapped gifts
that's right I had a lot it was a lot of
[ __ ] going on yeah that's right I have
to say after my kids are you know teens
now so it's like easier those days are
those Christmases up until they were
like 10 are just a firestorm just of
work and stuff and gotta get it all put
in and make it so special
I also like that you queue up the train
going around the Christmas tree that's a
class act like that that's like you
suppose I got I gotta up my that is the
best my game on I'll help you with that
next year yeah you know was really good
at that too is a in a total different
level is Billy Gardell really yeah he's
got like he went down the rabbit hole
and has like whole spaces that are just
for his trains oh yeah Sopranos right
yeah yeah I used to live my first
apartment I moved out here with Nia
there was a guy across the street and
every once while he opened the garage
yeah door and he had the train hat he
had all of this stuff and I was like
smile and he kind of looked at me like I
was weird like looking at me like what
do you think I'm a [ __ ] weirdo and
I'm like now I admired I buyer this we
just live in a city with too many people
so I'm not allowed to say hello right I
don't know their conductor who doesn't
really drive a [ __ ] train um
appreciate your goddamn hobby there all
right that's the podcast everybody
really no worries
you're doing great on streaming now on
the Netflix's on the Netflix's and it'll
be a little bit of music and then a
bonus half-hour from a Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
morning podcast all right have a great
weekend you bastards hey what's going on
it's Bill Byrne it's the Monday morning
podcast from Monday February 6 2012
what's going on you know what the [ __ ]
going on you [ __ ] ah Jesus Christ I'm
actually recording this thing an hour
and maybe hour and changed after the
Patriots just lost to the New York
Giants congratulations to the Giants oh
my god that game was [ __ ] brutal
brutal game I got myself all mentally
prepared to get our asses kicked cuz on
paper I was like we just our defense
isn't gonna be good enough and at that
front
four of Adonis's that they have that
looked like super sized linebackers and
next thing you know we come out and
we're playing with them and with fun we
just I just I don't know you know we
just didn't make the [ __ ] plays when
we needed to make the place that's all
there is to it the Giants did everything
they could to give us the game they blew
the [ __ ] to call in two timeouts I'm
like they're [ __ ] up there unraveling
after week spotted him nine points it
was like nobody wanted to win the game
for a minute we [ __ ] stopped him we
get the goddamn ball first play of the
game you throw a 50-yard intentional
ground in your own [ __ ] endzone
you're down two to nothing
alright regroup regroup they're driving
down the field you make a play you
caused a fumble you fall on it nice here
we go and next thing you know with down
nine nothing
and guess who texts me 9 to nothing
Charlie Murphy one of the classic
Fairweather fans of all time hey I have
until I you know I've known Charlie for
years I think we've had maybe three
conversations about football
Patriots even played the Giants and lost
during the regular season to him do you
think he even noticed he's too busy down
the dojo trying to figure out how to put
his foot behind his head in case some
[ __ ] comes up to him and tries
to steal this is I don't know the chain
off his neck he doesn't know [ __ ] about
football
he couldn't even [ __ ] talk [ __ ]
before the game he waited till they were
up 9 to nothing and he texts g-men all
day Charlie I know you could kick the
[ __ ] out of me
I don't know if you listening to that
this but that was one of the bitchiest
texts I ever got in my life alright so
congratulations to you Charlie
to you and your brand-new Giants hat
that you bought 9 to nothing is that
when you finally committed to buying it
whatever there's always gonna be guys
like that on both sides has definitely
fair weather people in Boston with your
pink
Red Sox hat she [ __ ] singing that Neil
Diamond song I hope you all [ __ ]
drown on a duck boat darling we started
playing alright we were coming back
everything was going good and then we
had the game we [ __ ] had it Brady to
Welker I don't know what happened we had
the [ __ ] game and we just didn't make
the goddamn place and just didn't make
the plays and the Giants made the play
so they deserve it but this one [ __ ]
hurts more than 2 mm in 2007 I just felt
like look you know I mean it sucked the
end of the game but despite wheat the
fact that we lost at the end of the game
I just really felt that that was just an
undeniable championship they you know
all those teams they beat on the road
and then they beat the undefeated
Patriots I just you know I always felt
it was a shame the Patriots are
undefeated because I never thought the
Giants got credit because it didn't it
wasn't the Giants won it was the
Patriots lost like that was the [ __ ]
story but this one hurts [ __ ] but if
you were true sports fan you saw what
happened alright but this one this one
was brutal because we we [ __ ] it we
had it and I just felt like we we just
blew it we [ __ ] blew it and I know it
sounds like I'm taking away from the
Giants I'm not because that [ __ ] pass
that pass eli made i mean even if there
was nobody in front of them to make that
[ __ ] pass down along the sideline
single coverages are amazing through he
threw the double coverage with somebody
right in his face he had the alligator
arm it and he still put it right in
there was one of greatest passes i've
ever seen in my [ __ ] life the guy
just makes the place and the only silver
lining that I can take from all this is
he has more rings than his brother so
there you go cult fans now what do you
got to say with your [ __ ] brady
peyton manning arguments you know at
least tom brady has more rings than his
brother ah [ __ ] I'm really looking for
an angle to try and talk [ __ ] I can't
that's not what I do I take my [ __ ]
lumps the Giants deserve it just a great
[ __ ] organization and they got four
Super Bowls and that immediately moves
them
they were sort of mineral upper as far
as historical football franchise now
they got four all right so you got
Steelers got six 49ers and Cowboys got
five and then they're tied with four
with Green Bay so they're up there with
the Steelers the Packers the 49ers and
the Cowboys man that's great company so
you guys should be proud man I was
[ __ ] oh god I can't believe I got to
do this [ __ ] podcast I just keep it's
just I can't even explain it I felt like
I had an ice cream in my hand and I've
already put in my mouth and somebody
knocked the [ __ ] I'm left him standing
here with an empty cone oh god that was
a [ __ ] brutal one that was a brutal
brutal [ __ ] loss let's just [ __ ]
blew it and you whatever you know what
am I gonna do it's not like you know I'm
sure nobody in Cleveland has any [ __ ]
sympathy for me all right
so anyways you probably asked yourself
with Jeep Bill you know you're on a
plane tomorrow where the [ __ ] you going
oh by the way I'm not making fun of
Madonna for being in the in the halftime
show because I didn't even [ __ ] watch
it all right I really think that that
Madonna helped the Giants [ __ ] win
this now she didn't but I I'm gonna lie
to you if I wasn't freaking out during
that that [ __ ] you know we were down
9 to nothing we come back score like
[ __ ] whatever how many unanswered we
screw 10 to 9 it was 10 to 9 at halftime
and I'm thinking are we got it we got
the momentum we're getting the ball back
let's go in for a quick halftime now I'm
voguing with gay guys for [ __ ] a
goddamn half an hour now let me ask you
this who is whose advantage is that it's
a [ __ ] team that's reeling it's a
team that needs to take a knee any time
Fergie goes out there and shows her
[ __ ] ass for an extra half an hour I
want to know this fellow football
fans how the [ __ ] did we go from Bart
Starr and vince lombardi to that
horseshit
alright Jesus [ __ ] Christ with the
goddamn to our halftime [ __ ] show I
mean it's a [ __ ] theory because we
got the ball and them drove down and
scored a touchdown but it just was it's
just I don't know you know what why
can't they just be happy making billions
do they have to make billions and
billions billions so they have to [ __ ]
out the [ __ ] sport to that level that
every goddamn year you got to bring some
[ __ ] over the hill rock star to come
out there right I'd rather watch an
old-timers game you know I didn't even
watch a second or what did she do I
heard some of the music you know it's a
[ __ ] football game it's the
championship game does anybody else have
that does anybody else have voguing in
the middle of it don't do something
something something something something
vogue vogue vogue you know and were they
all doing their fierce faces dressed
like they're in Avatar you know like
they gonna get [ __ ] in the ass on
Avatar oh he's a better sports fan today
people you know I'm gonna try and blame
Madonna for the loss no no either way I
would have made fun of that [ __ ] all
right Bruce Springsteen sliding around
on his knees Prince coming out there
with the stupid purple high-heeled boots
all right we got it you like to lick
your lips okay with you little [ __ ]
and his little hair do you know coming
out there and it's little [ __ ]
jammie-jams to go sing a [ __ ] song
with this curlicue guitar at a [ __ ]
football game all right go down to
Guitar Center and teach somebody how to
do a [ __ ] I don't know play a goddamn
G chord get the [ __ ] off the field you
know if I was NFL Commissioner this is
what I would do that was one of the
first things I would do is I would get
rid of that ridiculous halftime [ __ ]
show all right I do SH that I would
actually be out stood by all the owners
all the things that I wouldn't want to
do
I would do that and there was something
else I wanted to do but I already
[ __ ] forgot it my brain just goes in
a straight line it was right there I had
the idea and I just blew by it to go
right to the Madonna [ __ ] and I can't
remember bouncing the dust the [ __ ] was
it oh I know what I would do I would
undo that rule that the Colts made that
the Colts pushed through that so now
everybody throws for 5000 [ __ ] yards
I would allow cornerbacks to cover you
know the cover receivers you know
Patriots got away with one I don't think
they were both bad calls but one of them
was yeesh you know there's nothing yeah
we got mean but both those calls could
have been pass interference we got away
with them you know we just [ __ ]
didn't take advantage of the [ __ ] you
know calls were going our way oh Jesus
anyways I was actually standing out on
the balcony drinking a [ __ ] beer
going I think they're gonna win I got a
good feeling you know they come out they
score a [ __ ] touchdown everytime poke
my head in you know she was sitting
there like a virgin who got [ __ ] 90
years ago whatever the [ __ ] she was
singing everything was all dressed in
this stupid whatever I don't you know
some I don't give a [ __ ] if you think
this podcast sucks you wait you want
your [ __ ] team lose the Superbowl
have your [ __ ] ripped out and then
you go talk for an hour in the goddamn
podcast alright you know what I need a
break here let's let's get into the
advertising for this week okay people
and so as I always mention as I always
mentioned all right if you're gonna buy
something on amazon.com if you're just
sitting there laying around going you
know what I think will fill the void if
I go to amazon.com and I go buy myself a
bellybutton ring you know why don't you
make a little detour go to bill burr
calm first click on the podcast page and
on the right hand side right next to the
iTunes little box there whatever you
call it the banner is the amazon.com you
click on there and that's all you need
to do just go to amazon.com through my
podcast page on Billboard calm okay
they'll give me a little kick back for
driving you there
it doesn't cost you any extra money to
buy you a little your little [ __ ] ring
whatever the [ __ ] you want to do okay
your little nose ring whatever you kids
are doing all right your little dj1 and
to thing you want to buy and I'm not
saying you got a bite don't get
defensive with me you don't have to buy
it don't buy it I don't give a [ __ ] but
if you gotta buy it on Amazon com just
go through my website they'll give me a
little kickback and then I take 10% of
that and I send it on to the Wounded
Warriors Project all right if you got a
problem with that you're not an American
what do think about that and I think
that I kick you right out of the [ __ ]
country how'd you like that how was that
for a nice advertising read after my
team lost the Super Bowl I thought that
was pretty good I think I only said [ __ ]
twice and the the other thing is
stamps.com stamps calm I've actually
been using this product you know kind of
like if Tom Brady was talking about uggs
Tom Brady said hugs are the most
comfortable shoes I've ever worn in my
life you know you two get half by the
way what was that Tom Brady photo shoot
who was the non football person that
they brought in for the photo shoots
this year you know they had the
offensive lineman doing that 1960s
football card pose even the e light one
where he brought the thing back you
could see it in his eyes like what am I
doing here
I usually just stand here and you take
my picture and then I know Tom Brady he
went for it I think he's been hanging
out with Gisele a little too long he did
a whole photo shoot thing am I'm doing
the pouty face with my fist on my chin
and now I'm doing what looks like I'm
jerking off and then I don't know why he
did he did the Charleston I don't know
what he did that was stuff it's the
Super Bowl we need it to be super let's
do some photo shoots
let's bring in Madonna somebody makes
some dip do you know why it's like the
Super Bowl really is like you know those
bug lights to attract mosquitoes it that
the Super Bowl is just for non sports
fan douchebags it really is it's because
it's the only sport where it
that's all you know one game all all the
marbles that's it okay he played for an
NBA championship it's best four out of
seven MLB best four out of seven Stanley
Cup best four out of seven okay
so it do you got to be a real fan to
stick it out for at least four or five
[ __ ] games
you know Super Bowl all you got to do is
just show up and everybody shuts up
during the [ __ ] commercials and then
they did they run their goddamn mouth
but I want to actually went to a good
Super Bowl party but anyways that's
that's not what I'm here to talk about
people okay better team one I'm gonna
put it in the past and I am NOT gonna
discuss it at all during this next
advertising read game face on game face
all right make the place unlike your
team okay make the [ __ ] play here all
right stamps calm everybody I've
actually been using this product I got
to tell you something it's awesome man I
don't have to go to the post office
anymore they mailed me a little scale
you know they did everything but sit
give me that little visor hat that
you're supposed to wear like mr. McFeely
used to have or was it less investment I
don't know but basically what you can do
in your own damn house with the computer
and your printers you can buy and print
official US postage all right you use
your own computer and your printer it's
quick it's easy and getting started took
me uh well it should only take you five
minutes but if you're more unlike me
takes you about seven I'm not gonna lie
to you alright so they got a special
offer going on if you if you go to at
stamps com just enter my last name ber
be you are are you get a no risk trial
plus 110 dollar bonus offer which
includes a digital scale and fifty five
bucks worth of free postage for a
limited time only all right it's always
a limited time only because we're trying
to get you to what advertising 101
limited time only you get a hundred and
ten dollar bonus awful offer you get a
digital scale and fifty-five dollars in
stamps okay they doing that over at Best
Buy I don't think they are it's for a
limited time only okay so don't wait
exclamation point go to stamps calm
before you do anything else click on the
radio mic
phone at the top of the homepage that's
crucial and you type in Burpee you are
are all right stamps comm bu RR and I
actually mailed out my DVDs using it I
didn't have to go down a post off and
stand you know in line behind some old
lady with dementia trying to mail a
peanut butter and jelly sandwich to some
guy who was in the Benny Goodman band
who died in 1978 I don't have to do that
I did it in my my goddamn underwear I
mailed out my DVDs for this week okay ah
you know it's funny after the Super Bowl
I just have to talk about after the
Super Bowl party okay when your team
loses all right this is what you do you
just you don't watch ESPN
you know I answer the phone cuz I cuz I
you know I love my friends when they
break my balls okay I take the [ __ ]
alright antique Anthony cumbia called me
up that gun nut okay that uh that that
little that little warm mongerer out
there in the cul de sac who just never
grew out of playing cowboys and Indians
you know he never grew out of that or
having a goatee you know he just that
man loves the past all right he calls me
up out of nowhere you know asking me
stuff he doesn't even know anything
about the game doesn't know anything
about sports and I was like Anthony you
[ __ ] bastard
what the [ __ ] are you calling me for but
I loved him so I took the call and he
painstakingly made me go through the
details of the game he didn't even give
a [ __ ] about you know you know it's
funny is he sounded like he was in a bar
and he was actually in his own goddamn
house I'm telling you I don't know why
they keep doing stories on Hugh Hefner
they really they got to start talking
about Anthony he is the East Coast Hugh
Hefner you know whatever so anyway so
I'm driving home and I'm trying to avoid
hearing anything about the game I'm
thinking all right I'm in Los Angeles
you know they don't have a football team
you know I listen to the top 40 station
some wasn't this awful top 40 stuff and
even then I figured I was going to get
away I didn't
to listen to Italy I Betty what's the
good beats the Louisville appropriate
stop ready yeah you know you looked okay
but I don't listen to anything that I've
listened to this top 40 horseshit you
know classic hits or something the guys
late coming up next we got men at work
speaking of men at work the Giants were
men at work today when I beat the bakery
I was like ah you [ __ ] [ __ ]
I can't get away I can't get away from
it so tomorrow I got to go to the
airport
all right I got to go to the goddamn
Airport I know it's gonna be on the
cover of all that [ __ ] thing but I
don't I got a mitt I actually like the
Giants and I like Eli I do I just like
the style of football that they play and
I wish we would draft offensive [ __ ]
linemen that looked like the guy I gotta
tell you something that kid there whose
dad was in the crowd and they told that
whole story about our this grandfather
was blind and then he built half the
town you know and everything was where
it was supposed to be whatever whatever
the [ __ ] story they were telling that
play where we will write down on the
goal line even though we scored where
they handed it to Ben Jabba's green
Alice right how the [ __ ] he was able to
tackle that guy for a law is one of the
most amazing plays I've ever seen that's
like some Lawrence Taylor [ __ ] but he's
doing it as a defensive tackle it was
frightening you know as fun as actually
watching a game with one of the Patriots
fans who was like one of those guys who
cheers when the other team gets injured
and even all the other Pats fans were
like come on man really you gonna bring
that karma on to us so what are you
gonna do oh here's two things man here's
two things that I want to give you guys
the heads up on fans of Patrice O'Neal
Rolling Stone wrote a great article
about him a four-page article not some
little blurb this is a four-page article
and you know it's got all the big guys
out there you know Chris Rock louis c.k
everybody talking about you know just
how unbelievable a comedian he was and
I'm gonna tell you right now you know
that you are the best of the best when
guys like that go out of there
to mention it and rolling stone is gonna
write four pages you know honoring you
and you know at the level that he that
he was at you know what I'm saying it's
like you know if somebody on you know
Nurse Jackie
died or something you know because
you're on Nurse Jackie that was
literally four pages because of what he
did as a stand-up comedian no [ __ ]
no oh this is this guy from this movie
he's the guy from the [ __ ] trucks
that turn in a robot's movie let's give
this guy a piece that was just
straight-up this guy's was such a beast
you know we're gonna give up four pages
so I'm really happy that they did that
you know so definitely check that out
and you know Patrice O'Neal CD mr. P is
coming out this week I can't remember it
was February 5th of the seventh but uh
please download it off of iTunes if you
do anything all right please download it
this week cuz all that money is gonna go
to his to his family you know his wife
his stepdaughter and his mom and it
would really mean a lot to me if you
guys could download that and you know
what's the great thing about it is I'm
telling you to download the material of
the best comic I ever saw all right
there I said it
the guy was was the best so please
please please please please download mr.
P off iTunes all right and that's it
okay now back to the damn podcast here
why this this always [ __ ] happens to
me I gotta start doing like the [ __ ]
Thursday morning podcast that's what I
gotta start doing so I can take him on
Wednesdays so he seems like I have to
deal some crushing [ __ ] defeat that
time when the Jets beat the Patriots in
a playoff game that was a Sunday night I
was in [ __ ] what the hell was I I was
in Atlantic City then I had to go up in
front of Jets fans no gives a [ __ ] I do
obviously you know I'm already getting
past it what am I gonna do was Tom Brady
gonna buy me a corned beef sandwich if
you [ __ ] want it
what was with that photo shoot who the
[ __ ] cleared that Jesus alright let's
let's get on with the podcast here then
I don't know if this is true or anything
somebody sent me this thing Don
Cornelius the founder of Soul Train
successful show soul to the legendary
show successful plays d with insurance
money I don't know you know this guy was
big enough maybe you guys some people
didn't know Don Cornelius unfortunately
it looks like he committed suicide 75
years of age he was the host of the Soul
Train why am I trying to talk about Soul
Train you guys know I didn't watch that
[ __ ] he's a legend okay that was outside
my wheelhouse but I totally respect the
guy so anyways the guy allegedly killed
himself so according to humor milcom and
I got to tell you something you know
what I think of you know quality
reporting
I think of humor milcom who the [ __ ] is
humor milcom does that even sound
legitimate here's what they're reporting
we hear according to reliable sources
that Don was having a very bad bout with
cancer and while this was going on he
was in a bitter dispute with his wife
over the insurance money that would be
delegated to her upon his death from the
deadly disease our sources state that
Don wanted the money to be given to his
son Tony Tony but because of his
marriage and his failing health the
insurance was to be given to his wife
does that make any sense because his
marriage and his failing health what
does his failing health have to do with
who gets the insurance money
see this none of this makes sense I'll
read it anyways Don made the decision to
take his own life since the his doctor
stated he had only weeks to live
Don probably suspected that life
insurance doesn't pay anything if
someone commits suicide but California
is different if you had the policy for
more than two years the policy pays for
a suicide and Don's policy was more than
two years old
Jesus Christ California really takes the
no-fault state you know to a whole
nother level
you know you get married out here your
wife goes across the street and goes hey
honey
with like a dick in her mouth you know
and there's it's not her fault even
suicide isn't your fault dude you want
to talk about a story that's just built
on sand Don probably suspect go [ __ ]
yourself what did I even read that what
a [ __ ] thing to do to a legend I
apologize let's move on staking a
[ __ ] date bill I'm only 15 minutes
into the latest podcast and I feel that
I must inform you that there is a
Valentine's Day for men it's called
steak and a [ __ ] day is it really
does hallmark make cart cards for that
it's celebrated March 14th
one month after Valentine's Day it's
simple the way show their man
appreciation by cooking a mistake and
giving them a [ __ ]
I remember this movement gaining some
momentum with people my age 23 a while
back but then I haven't heard anything
about it in years yeah it's amazing you
know I've been watching the news lately
and I've seen plenty of stuff plenty of
stuff on Valentine's Day I haven't
really heard coming up next has
everybody got their shopping writing the
women I'm standing out here live in
front of the grocery store there's a
pandemonium women are trying to buy
steaks get out they got the [ __ ]
thing down but they need that meat is
everything that you guys are sending me
horse [ __ ] this week a few years ago I
remember seeing people posting about it
on Facebook on March 14th including
girls saying that they would be
participating this movement needs a
second push of momentum it needs a
celebrity endorsement
it needs Bilborough I thought you needed
a celebrity what level of show business
am I in okay I feel like I'm slowly
getting to VJ level I mean like a
Lemay's famous is a VJ maybe you know in
my more
ignitable than the jack-in-the-box guy's
voice anyways I know you could explain
and defend this holiday from haters I'm
pretty sure it started in your own
hometown of Boston to promote steak and
a [ __ ] day on the podcast and be a
part of history
toot I don't know how to promote this
well I can give you some advice first
thing you need to do is you need to come
up with a euphemism for [ __ ] alright
because if it's sneaking a [ __ ] day
you're really limiting you know the
amount of people that you can reach out
to you know it's like you kind of go in
like death metal they're like Hallmark
isn't gonna make you know cutesy little
cards with like dicks on them and like a
[ __ ] steak grilling in the background
like I don't know how the [ __ ] you would
do that so I don't know I don't know my
[ __ ] team lost the Super Bowl I can't
even make steak in a [ __ ] day funny
what the [ __ ] do you want from me
I'm playing hurt on this one okay oh my
god it's not that they lost it's that
they [ __ ] blew it had [ __ ] had it
just [ __ ] catch the goddamn ball
keep going down the field kick a little
[ __ ] field goal give it back to them
they've blown their - [ __ ] - what are
three timeouts it's taking a [ __ ] day
you know what I'm so old how about [ __ ]
off day that's what I would like [ __ ]
off just 24 hours just [ __ ] off no for
24 hours I don't want to be in another
room just getting comfortable in here 24
hours of not that 24 hours of I just
just don't want at any point to be like
are you done watching the TV because I
wanted to watch my shows now I want
to watch I wanted to watch my shells can
I watch my shows hey honey
[ __ ] off do be me to be its [ __ ] off day
[ __ ] off means it means [ __ ] off for 24
hours okay you know what's funny is they
couldn't do it they couldn't do it David
see that the Sun is down the days over
god it's really the whole yes it's a
whole day [ __ ] off you don't really have
to leave your house for [ __ ] off day do
you realize that just how [ __ ] I'm
such a maniac do you know today I was
driving into the supermarket and I was
getting some blue moon for the Super
Bowl that my team lost god damn it and
this is the latest people that I just
fantasized blowing the brains right out
of back of their [ __ ] skulls those
[ __ ] douche bags they see you sitting
in your [ __ ] car waiting for the spot
and they get everything in the car real
quick and then when they get in the
[ __ ] car they just sitting it what
the [ __ ] you doing
that's one girl just looking at me you
know she was older like in like we're
like our early 60s and she was still
trying to look hot when these Eastern
European I must break you
[ __ ] looks in her face you know I
immediately thought she was involved in
illegal activity does that make me
racist or does it make me self-hating
because they're considered white people
in this country Eastern European people
all look [ __ ] shady to me
they all look [ __ ] shady that they've
either been in a gulag or sent somebody
to the [ __ ] they know they're doing
something I got some sort of
black-market [ __ ] going on there just
shady looking people you know I don't
like saying right now I don't trust them
there you go that's my people
that's straight across the board I don't
[ __ ] trust him all right my
grandmother doesn't trust the Japanese
because of Pearl Harbor I don't trust
the [ __ ] Eastern Europeans because of
the Cold War my whole life I was told
that they were gonna [ __ ] blow me up
I don't trust
I'm talking about stealing fruit
hey let's read this let's read this
shall we
Charlie Murphy right now is probably
ordering Sports Illustrated and getting
that little cheap-ass football you know
dancing around trying to act like he you
know looking up football words stealing
fruit hey Bill I've heard your views on
the automated checkout machines and it
got me thinking while I was grocery
shopping I was looking at the price of
organic tomatoes first is you know what
I was just thinking about the time I
walked out of the Super Bowl we lost to
the Packers how much that hurt and I
wasn't even thinking about what the [ __ ]
I was just reading let me start over
again hey Bill I heard your views on
automated checkout machines and it got
me thinking well I was grocery shopping
I was looking at the price of organic
Tomatoes versus regular Tomatoes and the
price was triple moments after I had
what alcoholics call a moment of clarity
I'm gonna scheisse the [ __ ] out of this
grocery store oh I love it
I totally advocate this move I love the
direction you're going in that's right
make it work for you sir I load it up on
every expensive fruit and vegetable I
could find everything organic the weird
exotic fruit you never buy because it's
ten dollars a pound
all of it I even went to the make your
own salad bar by the pound and made a
vicious salad that made it hard to snap
the plastic clothes because I emptied
all the chicken breast and artichokes in
it I went oh that I skimp on oh that I
usually skimp on because it makes it oh
who's this a New York sports fan oh god
this is my brother he was at the game I
gotta take this hold on all right I'm
back sorry about that so anyways what
the hell was that this guy schiessen the
supermarkets he goes I usually skimp on
the chicken breast because it's the
heaviest so now he's loading up see what
the hell this is gonna go I went to the
automate automated checkout machine you
don't have the produce code it asks you
to look it up yourself
I entered every I entered everything
wrong for some reason I thought
asparagus was parsley and the rest of
this [ __ ] was potatoes I weight
everything
place that in the bag as my voice is all
cracking from screaming the bag even the
salad bar box somehow got entered as
iceberg lettuce it wait it waited and
told me to put it in the bag I had my
best foreign accent on deck just in case
they caught on and tried to bust me I
was gonna play it off and pretend I
couldn't even speak English let alone
read it I paid and I left the store with
80 bucks worth of produce for only six
dollars and seventeen cents ever since
that day I've been eating gourmet salads
and organic vegetables like a [ __ ] them
like you said I don't work here it's not
my job to know what the [ __ ] the
difference between a Roma tomato and an
organic tomato is if you want this [ __ ]
done right don't depend on broke college
students to be part to be a produce
expert there you go good for you sir god
damn it I almost wish I didn't read that
because somebody who makes those
machines will know they'll they'll
figure it out eventually but they
haven't figured out yet people all right
we're in a recession if you want to eat
healthy this guy just gave you the keys
well why can't you do that with
everything why don't you go buy yourself
a big t-bone steak for [ __ ] [ __ ]
and steak day right and you know just
enter and it is like [ __ ] Cheerios be
great you can eat like Donald Trump and
just [ __ ] yeah just wow that's
[ __ ] amazing I think I like those
automated machines now now I don't I
don't have that in me I advocate
stealing for people like that but I'm
just I'm not one of those guys I don't
like my karma is too [ __ ] strong
whenever I do [ __ ] like that
whatever I do [ __ ] like that I always
get [ __ ] it's like something happens
I get away with it and then I dropped my
cellphone in the [ __ ] toilet I just I
just don't have that in me you know
believe me I want to do it I am a piece
of [ __ ] I am a dirtbag you know you know
what bill maybe you're just not good at
stealing anyways advice hey Bill loved
the podcast I'm gonna make this quick
let's see how long this is this isn't
[ __ ] quick girl this [ __ ] I have to
read she's gonna make this quick okay
dated abroad for six years got engaged
too much later she says she's not ready
dumper
it's over dude she said we live together
we look together at the time less than a
week later her new 40 year old boyfriend
/ coworker my ex is 28 as am I is
sitting in the front of my house in the
driver's seat of her car I basically
told her to get the [ __ ] out she agreed
that lowly [ __ ] wow she dumped you for a
40 year old guy does he make money why
would she do that
Christ this guy's [ __ ] pubes are gonna
look like Jay Leno's head within [ __ ]
eight years why would she do that fast
forward a year and things couldn't get
better for me great job awesome roommate
and most of all no daily drama due to
the fact that we have many mutual
friends I've missed certain events
because I have missed certain events
because she was going this is no problem
as I have plenty of other [ __ ] to do
just sucks knowing that she is more
likely prying herself into my friends
heads and filling them with [ __ ]
they know how our brain works me which
means she's probably painting this of
how she wishes her and I could be
friends to my close people this is
complete [ __ ] and she hasn't made an
effort to contact me once well has she
done this he just inventing this in your
head she even goes as far according to
Chloe I guess okay
according to close friends has to bring
up a fatal jet skiing accident I was
involved in last July and how worried
she was again not a single call or a
text well - what happened with the jet
ski this is more compelling than this
this [ __ ] petty [ __ ] that you're
talking about how the [ __ ] can you bring
up dude this thing went from some office
[ __ ] to a goddamn Schwarzenegger
movie now we're back in the office again
again not a single call or a text
honestly I want nothing to do with the
[ __ ] so whatever she actually reminds
me of that girl the self-loathing
narcissistic one that sucks
all the air out of the room that Nia
chimed in about on a podcast earlier
seven eleven eleven I believe whenever
I'm out with friends and her filthy what
the [ __ ] is that word gang gangrenous
vag shows up gangrenous did you invent a
word it's not underlined in red I've
never seen that word I respectfully say
my good-byes and leave i rebounded with
a cute server for a few months and
lately haven't seen or heard much from
her the ex is aware that we have been
hooking up and come to find out somehow
managed to learn her 21 year old
impressionable mind in to tonight for
example they walk into a bar with a few
other folks and I watch my ex-fiancee
prompt her to come say hi is it to let
me know they've been hanging out dude
why don't you get out of this girl's
world what do you live in a one-horse
town there's one little saloon one
[ __ ] Applebee's anyways he goes I'm
above all of it and had the foresight to
realize such things were possible as
she's a narcissistic manipulative [ __ ]
bottom line my best friend is getting
married in a couple of months I'm a
groomsmen and the exes in the bridal
party Jesus need some advice is how to
handle it what are you over go to the
[ __ ] weddings you have a good time
take your dick out and go on the dance
floor try to [ __ ] one of her friends I
don't know whatever you want to do just
have a good time have a good [ __ ]
time this girl is obviously miserable
who [ __ ] trades in a [ __ ] 28-year
old stud for some 40 year old guy yeah
she she [ __ ] up dude you holding all
the cards you're still in the prime of
your [ __ ] life just go there and have
a good time have some drinks and this is
what let her walk around the room and
tell everybody what an [ __ ] you are
and then just be a good [ __ ] and then
they're gonna be like you know should
just be that crazy person following you
around I would
you know she walks up to you don't look
her in the eye look at her hands alright
just in case okay she [ __ ] is annoyed
that everybody still likes you when she
decides to do a Glenn Close
I don't know I don't understand your
problem sir like I think he should just
[ __ ] live your life and stop going to
[ __ ] that she's gonna be at you can't
find another bar to drink at you know
what you do next time you see her just
be like hey you put your arms out like
you're gonna hug her and just booter
right in the box just take the [ __ ]
misdemeanor that's a misdemeanor isn't
its below the waist you know above the
waist I think it's a sult below the
waist I believe you know I believe that
it's a is it misdemeanor right kick her
in the box or go to a bar she's not at
okay you need this decision time number
two so I'm a twenty one twenty year old
college student who works at a grocery
still so I haven't gotten laid in a few
months and jerking off to online porn is
getting more and more degrading and
uninteresting but recently a chicken
dude I can't even focus on these things
I keep thinking about the [ __ ] game
but recently a chick at work has been
coming on to me and we've been texting
really sexual [ __ ] well congratulations
sir you'll never be able to run for
president and from pretty confident I
could bang her even though she has a
boyfriend oh you know I was just
thinking about that is how you know
they're saving all this [ __ ] all this
[ __ ] lurid [ __ ] that we're looking at
on the internet all our text messages
I'm predicting this in 20 years when I'm
an old [ __ ] I'm in my 60s and these
young whippersnappers from this
generation are they're running for
president that's what's gonna be coming
up you know is it true that in nineteen
[ __ ] no that's too far back is it
true in 2009 you texted to one of your
[ __ ] coworkers that you wanted to
stick your tongue up ur ass is this the
kind of person we want running the
country it's gonna be all that [ __ ]
why didn't you jerk off - a woman gets
groped on subway in February of 2008
I don't recall I let my roommate use my
computer I watched it but did not touch
myself that'll be the I smoked that but
didn't inhale line in 20 years was that
choppy enough for you guys did you did
you even hear the joke and my choppy
[ __ ] my team just lost the Super Bowl
[ __ ] delivery anyways he says but
[ __ ] isn't it her responsibility not to
cheat if she's putting it out there like
that and I think it's my duty as a man
to [ __ ] her I don't know what you're
talking about sir I have no [ __ ] idea
my team lost the Super Bowl we go back
here twenty-year-old college to him
we're gonna cross the store I'm in late
I'm jerking off the porn chicks been
coming on to me she has a boyfriend yeah
yeah [ __ ]
then he luck she'll get caught that guy
won't knock her up and marry her anyways
he said I was an effort boyfriend finds
out hey he can dump her and knowing that
she's a cheating [ __ ] there you go and
I would be done with her forever sort of
okay maybe not but even though it's
morally wrong to have sex with someone
with the girl who has a boyfriend we are
20 years old and it's like she's married
or anything and she's basically waving a
steak in front of a hungry dog what
should I do that [ __ ] in the cereal
aisle though it who gives a [ __ ] you're
20 years old
it's what you're supposed to be doing
wear a condom all right bend her over
that little caution floor has just been
mopped son push ahead right into the mop
bucket and let her have it [ __ ] it who
gives a [ __ ] my [ __ ] team lost a
Super Bowl I don't give a [ __ ] about my
boyfriend's feelings next one hey Bill
I'm a twenty world call at 21 year old
college student going to Washington
State University home I drew bledsoe
this has been my first year away from
home and it's been an adventure to say
the least my 21 for 21st birthday was
the first time I drank and I've been
hanging out with girls for the first
flipping time in my life god bless you
sir for keeping your innocence that long
that you didn't have any booze till you
were 21 you're finally hanging out with
girls and you still don't say [ __ ] you
say flippin for the first flippin time
of my life I love this guy
I've always been incredibly nervous
around women and I have no game at all
well the first thing you do is stop
saying flippin you don't you say flip
and you say flipping for the first
flippin time in my life actually you
know what dude why don't you stay just
be a nice guy all right don't don't go
down the road I went okay there's a
price you pay you become a miserable
[ __ ] like me anyways the one
accomplishment that I have under my belt
is moving into an apartment with two
beautiful girls this semester [ __ ]
Jack Tripper one one of which has been
the girl I had a crush on since I was 12
12 years old
embarrassing I know she has a boyfriend
and I've pretty much accepted the fact
that he's a nice guy
I'm just glad that I get to hang out
with her god I sound like a douche all
right dude I swear to God if you go into
your bedroom while she's in the living
room and you jerk off to her alright
that's a level of loneliness that you do
not want to experience I really hope
that you haven't done it yet
please don't do that anyways he says I'm
sick and tired of being this incredibly
nervous 21 year old virgin virgin who's
living in babe country every time I see
a hottie I can't help but think I will
never be able to get her well now with
that [ __ ] attitude your whole [ __ ]
you listen you got to get yourself out
of right field that's what you are right
now you're that kid ah goddamn I'm
really required to stick to sake kid in
for 3 innings you're batting 9th please
for the love of God bill give me some
advice all right this is the last one of
these trying to help the 21 year old
version guys I'm [ __ ] doing ok I give
advice about this every [ __ ] week how
about somebody get about something else
can we get it out of the wheel
the [ __ ] relationships here give you
some advice I don't know what to tell
you dude all right start talking to
women this is the first thing you want
to do
don't try and [ __ ] anybody you live in
with [ __ ] all of that all right you want
to get that girl go out and [ __ ]
start banging a bunch of other women and
come home and then all of a sudden
you're gonna seem like you're mysterious
when you're 21 years old and you're
banging a bunch of women when the women
your age look at you like you like a spy
or something like you're James Bond you
do it at my age and you're just a
[ __ ] pig
all right that's what you need to do
need to go out and get hammered you need
to go out you got to get in the mix you
got to go out and do some [ __ ] you got
you got to create some sort of vibe all
right you can't just be like hi how you
doing Cheri and leave me in my room you
know and then just [ __ ] sitting there
jerking off in there you got to get out
of there all right you need a little bit
of swagger [ __ ] that [ __ ] that you've
liked for nine years for almost half you
[ __ ] life [ __ ]
it's not gonna happen okay it's over
she's sucking someone else's dick
someone else's flippin dick sir that's
what you need to do you need to go out
you need to get a little [ __ ] you got
a little gotta get a little mud on your
uniform you know what I mean
got to win a couple of games you know a
little bit of swagger and then one day
you're gonna walk in there and you're
gonna catch her in the right move all
right and you're gonna undo her [ __ ]
sweatpants and you got a bent her over
that poor excuse for a [ __ ] sofa
ain't gonna show her who's what all
right and then when a boyfriend shows up
you're both not gonna say anything and
you gotta get on with your life you're
gonna go in there and you're gonna make
yourself some popcorn that's what the
[ __ ] you want to do sir I have no advice
for you I don't know what to tell you
all right I think a lot of what you're
doing is great you know you're like a 21
you're a virgin you know what you like
you like one of those Star Wars action
figures that's still in the package you
know you're worth a lot of money so you
you know you there's two routes you can
go here you can find
you can [ __ ] you can you can stay
this route join the church choir pray to
God you know get molested by some
closeted [ __ ] psycho right and then
meet some nice girl who plays the
keyboards keep in mind that Jesus Christ
has died for you can hook up with her
you know
peel off 420 levels of clothes or you
can just go 0 to 100 and just go find
some dirty skank you don't want to do
that - you don't ok you know what you
need to do you need to work it out
yourself the last thing you need to do
is listen to some [ __ ] piece-of-shit
dirtbag never been married no [ __ ]
kids sliding into [ __ ] fifty years of
age you don't need to listen to me ok
what you need to do is you need to stick
with what you're doing ok at this point
I'm sure you [ __ ] Eagle Scout I bet
you can start a fire without matches you
know and uh you know I don't probably
got a sweater you know dark colored
socks I don't know what to tell you dude
like what you're doing is actually
commendable that you're that [ __ ]
untainted and look at you you call you
just sitting here you [ __ ] saying you
got a crush on this girl what do you do
and what do I do i teii I send you down
this piece-of-shit road I think you need
to listen to another podcast sir I bet
that Joel Olsteen could tell you what to
do you know Jesus Jesus wants you to get
that [ __ ]
do you realize Joel Olsteen he his
[ __ ] church is where the Houston
Rockets used to play mega church mega
church this suburb our church never
looks so good right Jesus comes in
[ __ ] shredded wearing a male funk you
know
[ __ ] that means do they make a mail
phone overrated underrated for the
[ __ ] week oh I'm playing hurt this
week 51 minutes that's not bad
alright the end of you [ __ ] think you
could be even remotely this amusing
after your team just [ __ ] blew the
goddamn Super Bowl overrated underrated
for the week alright what is this one
underrated unemployment it may suck to
lose a job you love but when you get
canned from a soul-crushing mind-numbing
daily head [ __ ] of a job where your boss
is a little piece of [ __ ] with an anger
problem why did that have a question
mark on it as long as you can have nice
fat a nice fat savings account and you
can keep from losing the house while you
kick back and take it easy for a few
months or years don't forget about
unemployment insurance they will pay you
for over two years to sit on your ass
and encourage you to do it it doesn't
hurt my pride one little bit to get back
a small portion of all that tax money
the government stole from me over the
years [ __ ] them you get to sleep in
every day go to the gym while it's empty
and drink on a school night I would
never go back if you didn't have to if I
didn't have to yeah do it I got to tell
you man
yeah you know what you're living you're
living the life of a comedian except you
don't have to go out and do a set that
night not Jesus is that gonna be it is
that the podcast for this week I got it
I got a summer I got to put in an hour
here somehow got to put in an hour I
don't know what to [ __ ] tell you guys
I really don't oh I know what I forgot
to mention this week ProFlowers
Valentine's Day is coming up everybody
when are you gonna proflowers.com for
some reason they took that banner off my
website they told me they go we want to
have banner on your website that we have
the ability to change and they they just
completely took the thing down so I
don't know what that means you know I
probably should have called them you
know but they took
down you won't you wanted all that
control ProFlowers I don't know what I'm
supposed to be talking about this week
all I know is Valentine's Day is coming
up and I advocate you know I advocate
going out on the 15th when you can get a
goddamn reservation it doesn't cost 90
[ __ ] grand
all right who's kidding who all right I
didn't get any goddamn coffee this week
[ __ ] it I'm just gonna wing this one all
right it's Valentine's Day everybody you
got to celebrate her and her [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's what's going down you don't
want to shop so once you proflowers.com
bouquet of flowers and slap her right in
the [ __ ] [ __ ] with it why don't you
do that just go on there flowers calm
click on the [ __ ] and enter be you
[ __ ] are are and get yourself a
bouquet of flowers shove the vase in her
ass and you have yourself a lovely day
save the chocolates for yourself because
that's what it's about
um no Gigi didn't get me a copy what do
you want from me I have copy for next
week they have their desperate copy for
next week hey fellas Valentine's Day
tomorrow
you got a Federal Express some roses why
did I just do that that was total
self-sabotage I was finally making some
money on the [ __ ] podcast why would I
do something like that because my team
just lost the Super Bowl and I'm really
not feeling it I read enough ads to
cover my new pair of tube socks I need
to buy this week hey Bill what are you
gonna be this week I'll tell you where
I'm gonna be I'm doing the redneck tour
I'm coming down south
[ __ ] South's gonna rise again hey
anyway let me tell you something we
start if we all got together we created
a co-op right like that did on that show
The Wire except it's all white people
where it should be if we create a co-op
appearing out of all our [ __ ]
moonshine stills we took all the money
we make instead of buying a new pair of
overalls or sticking a [ __ ] 500 cubic
inch engine into a [ __ ] Vega we
combined all that money we could buy
some gray uniforms and South rise again
we could do that [ __ ] I'm gonna be in
Charlotte North Carolina
on Tuesday
at the comedy zone the comedy [ __ ]
hut I don't know where the hell I'm
gonna be gonna be Charlotte North
Carolina Ric Flair if you listening to
my podcast anybody knows Ric Flair I got
a [ __ ] whoo I got tickets for him if
he wants to come down will be an
absolute honor to meet arguably one of
the top 5 funniest [ __ ] on a
microphone ever and then on the what is
it gonna be February 8th Wednesday I'm
gonna get my rental car East mantle down
loaded up and truckin I'm gonna drive
all the way over to Alabama Alabama the
only [ __ ] state that Georgia can make
fun of I'm gonna go into Alabama and I'm
gonna be at this dome for one show in
one show only and then the next day I'm
gonna go into Atlanta Georgia
Lana Georgia on nine and we'll be at the
[ __ ] what is it the Buckhead theater
and I'm gonna be doing I'm get listen
I'm getting ready to do my my big
stand-up special on March 3rd at the
Lincoln Theater in Washington DC - shows
and so what you will be seeing you will
be seeing comedian freaking out now
you'll be seeing a comedian putting
together what you're really gonna see is
me just [ __ ] around that's what
you're gonna see doing the hour that I
think I'm gonna do [ __ ] around with
it and having fun with it you know we're
not going all [ __ ] crazy not going
all crazy with it I don't want to burn
it out I'm already sick of these [ __ ]
jokes people I'm not gonna lie to you
that's what that's when it's time to do
is special once you're standing on stage
going if I have to talk about this one
more [ __ ] night I'm gonna kill myself
and then you're like you know what I
think it's time to document this and
move on that's where I am in my life so
I'm gonna be driving the highways down
there and the good old South I'm gonna
have my head on a swivel looking for
some old cars and oh hey thanks to
everybody who helped me out to try and
find the parts for my truck man as I
told you I got this [ __ ] garage
bought this old house and the garage is
designed for a [ __ ] Model T Ford I'm
not even lying you okay the goddamn
garage is high enough to get a [ __ ]
truck with the lift kit on it but you
know you know those old cars back in the
days sat inside the wheel wells you know
inside them tires were on the outside
and you were on the inside you know
that's why there was all that date-rape
back then I mean he was sitting on top
of her and that's true that's true story
it's a true goddamn story and I'm
sticking with it
yeah thanks everybody who helped me out
with that and ordering the parts and
when they get here I'm gonna have some
friends of mine look over my shoulder as
I try and put them on and have them like
[ __ ] help me out you know what's
funny is I bought the oil because I'm
gonna change the oil in the [ __ ]
thing and for the life of me I can't
find the [ __ ] I looked under really
quick I can't [ __ ] find it my old
truck there was oil pans right in the
bottom and there was a little screw you
just undid the [ __ ] thing it was
right there I can't find the goddamn
thing
granted I was holding on my dog as it
was trying to eat a cat at the time and
I was sticking my big head you know I
loved about having a truck as my big
[ __ ] head can actually fit underneath
the truck without having to raise it up
at all but people have asked me to post
pictures of it I'm not gonna do it just
because nobody really has one out here
and this thing you know sticks out like
a sore thumb and you know I don't know
you know I don't need people driving
down the [ __ ] Street all right so
it's a 68 Ford f100 that's all I'm gonna
tell you three on the tree [ __ ] you
know what's funny is Nia is afraid of
the thing because it's loud as [ __ ] and
you know the other day I was trying to
cut in front of somebody and so I let
out the clutch too quickly and I stalled
it and then as I pushed it in and rolled
back before we get we get run into and
it's just she you know
she's a city girl you know she was
already afraid of driving and that type
of thing so she's never even heard of
standard transmission so she doesn't get
why it stalls she
the truck is broken and she thinks it's
too loud and that you bounce around too
much in it just everything that makes it
awesome she's kind of afraid of but uh I
think gradually maybe she'll like it I
don't know cuz I always want to take her
out that's point getting the old car you
know take your girl out for a drive have
you [ __ ] dog in the back right my
inner redneck hey by the way when I'm
out there could anybody uh give me some
food suggestions here cuz I'm on the
wagon here cuz I'm not even on the wagon
buy it on the wagon means I have one
scotch at night I have to stay in shape
so I don't become Billy fat face it a
little too much booze wait my last
[ __ ] special you know let it go I got
out a little out of control so I want to
be in shape for this one and so if you
guys know if you know some good
restaurants keep me away from the bars
but there's some good place like what is
there to do in Charlotte North Carolina
what do I have to get you know to eat
what is the thing what are you [ __ ]
known for out there other than having
the Bobcats you know what I mean and
Alabama the same thing what do you guys
known for huh besides having sex with
your cousins what are you guys known for
that's what you're known for all right
[ __ ] start with me Atlanta what are
you known for huh down low brothers the
Braves losing the World Series Stonewall
Jackson lighting a [ __ ] scarecrow on
fire and robert e lee i don't know oh
[ __ ] Jesus Christ
I'm done hour and two minutes go [ __ ]
yourselves congratulations to the the
franchise New York Giants and
congratulations to all the true New York
giant fans it's [ __ ] awesome man come
on dude for [ __ ] Super Bowl rings
that's the [ __ ] okay you know it is
that's the [ __ ] you can make a fist and
you got one for each goddamn finger
thumbs curling around no one can see
that one yet you know but who knows who
knows with [ __ ] Eli and the way you
guys draft defensive players it wouldn't
it wouldn't surprise me if Eli got his
third
you know it really wouldn't surprise me
man that guy is the [ __ ] man and he
finally got his due
you know good for him I'm not gonna lie
to you [ __ ] hurts but I'm not I'm not
a [ __ ] when I lose alright so
congratulations to you sons of [ __ ]
that's the podcast for this week go [ __ ]
yourself next week I'm doing a bunch of
gigs out in Jersey Long Island and in
New York I got all the dates up on my
website what the [ __ ] is it bill bird
calm Jesus Christ I forgot my website I
can't believe I did that [ __ ] with
ProFlowers guys do me a favor
don't don't [ __ ] say anything don't
be [ __ ] all right please for the love
of God who gives a [ __ ]
omit idiot all right go go [ __ ]
yourselves I'll talk to you next week